the Constitution prohibits the
government from censoring much of the
speech that we've come to know and love
but Facebook is imposing its own Silicon
Valley brand of political correctness on
its own social media platform and
Facebook banned provocateurs like alex
jones milo and even louis farrakhan and
now the social media giant is going a
step further by censoring conservative
commentator michelle malkin forget this
opposing facebook censorship Michelle
joins me now her first television
comments about all this Michelle in the
post that was taken down you said I
don't know how long it will be until I'm
next I so I loved it you kind of taunted
them and you demonstrated what was going
on but are you now on the verge do you
think of being just banned on Facebook
yeah I think a lot of us are and I think
there's a commonality among many of the
people who are being targeted on
Facebook and on Twitter on social media
I even have to worry about my own
website at Michelle Malkin calm which is
hosted by WordPress which is now going
after people based on their ideological
viewpoints
I do believe Laura that this is an
existential battle and I'm not saying
that just because it's self-serving
because I've made a living over the last
2025 years a lot of it are online and
never had to worry about this kind of
deep platforming I'm saying this because
we need a vibrant marketplace of ideas
we need an informed citizenry for a
constitutional republic to function and
when Facebook and Silicon Valley
overlords have their thumbs on the scale
of free speech that is a concern for all
of us look there's a lot of people
who've been deep lat formed that folks
out there might be uncomfortable with
but all I did that caused Facebook to
censor me Laura would simply stand up
for a couple of my friends Laura Loomer
and Gavin McInnes and now even I using
my Facebook platform that has 2.1
million followers cannot even mention
their names without being accused this
is violating it's ridiculous quote
community standards
of Facebook there's a lot more going on
here Laura and I believe that it has to
do with the 2020 election and making
sure that somehow those of us who
support the agenda of President Trump
are being throttled and managed and
marginalized and I'm sending up an alarm
I did at CPAC and I'll continue to use
my platforms to do it until they kick me
off yeah Michelle I love the defiance
and nick clegg of Facebook was on TV
this weekend and he basically issued a
know this warning the way that the rules
of the internet are drawn today in my
view or rather not drawn will be quite
different to the way they're drawn in 10
years time and I think big tech
companies have a choice either they play
ball and they try and pay a responsible
role in that debate or they try and duck
it altogether
well like the Europe has gotten all over
Facebook but a lot tougher frankly than
the United States and dealing with
privacy issues but he said this we
basically have no choice Michele yeah so
what do people do you know a lot of
people ask me after my CPAC speech and
over the past year now that we've seen
people disappear and be unperson and the
one thing that people can do is fight
back with their pocketbooks and fight
back with the voices that they do have
and support the people who have
disappeared there's a website called
fight the sensor's calm that's helping
people like Laura Loomer and Gavin
McGuinness whose names I can't say on
Facebook I'd like to see if I can test
the Facebook live stream function now
which is also being throttled apparently
if you violate their community standards
they'll take that away as well under
groups like the artificial or I'm care
that are going after them is how we have
to fight back Michelle Michelle Malkin
we're gonna continue to talk about this
with you at a later date thank you so
much stay there